eight seven
six five four
three two one
zero should we detonate nuclear weapons
for testing again
the world's nine nuclear nations have
performed over 2
000 nuclear tests but the comprehensive
test ban treaty
banned them because they were causing
radioactive contamination
and fueled nuclear proliferation
all nations stopped testing over 20
years ago
except for north korea which stopped in
2017
the us military now considers computer
simulations
so accurate that nuclear test explosions
are unnecessary but the us government
has recently floated the idea of
restarting nuclear testing
is that a good idea let's hear what some
nuclear
weapons experts think we and the soviets
in great britain signed the
limited test ban treaty forbidding all
tests of nuclear bombs in the atmosphere
as a result there have been no such
highly polluting atmospheric tests
anywhere in the world ever since
it's it's really imperative that the
nations of the world get together
and work toward eliminating the threat
of nuclear war
the resumption of nuclear testing that
is being considered by the trump
administration
does just the exact opposite and is very
likely to
reignite a nuclear arms race
both international law and national law
are wildly incompatible with these two
features the spectacular level to injure
and the solo act of it being brought
about by a single person
so we have the ability to dismantle this
architecture but in the meantime at the
very least
we have to abstain from actions such as
renewing the practice of testing a
return to nuclear testing does not just
impact nevadans
and those downwind residents who would
rightly fear
whether their groundwater was safe to
drink their air safe to breathe
and their cattle safe to graze a nuclear
war
cannot be won and must never be
fought if we get hit by thousands of
nuclear missiles or even if
they we don't but our nuclear missiles
go off as planned
then we would get earth envelope in a
cloud of soot and dust
that might lower the temperature over
nebraska by 40
fahrenheit and in fact make it snow in
the summer in most of the
agricultural reasons or regions on earth
which could easily kill 90
of everybody on the planet even a war
between india and pakistan could produce
global
climate catastrophe so we're still
working on this
trying to warn the world about any use
of nuclear weapons
and testing would just allow
other countries to expand their arsenals
and make the situation work
in this period of worldwide pandemic
scientists from all nations must
actively cooperate to make the world
safer resumption of nuclear weapons
testing would do just the opposite
making the world a much more secretive
and treacherous place
while diverting funds away from the
fight against a clear
and present danger we need to
stop spreading nuclear weapons we need
to be
sensible about this most scientists
know that nuclear weapons nuclear
testing
is a very bad thing i'd like to just end
by saying the comprehensive test ban
treaty
is an essential instrument
in controlling and eliminating
nuclear weapons we should ratify it
not abandon it to do otherwise would
also likely lead us to nuclear
catastrophe
whether by design or by accident
or through terrorist agency
you